na wer hätte gedacht ist da und nicht
ihr zuschauer so nah day
hallo hallo in diesem video unglaublich
wir haben es bereits im titel gelesen
wir brauchen heute ein video das nennt
ihr bester freund bruder dann hat man
dann sportlich jetzt beleidigt
bastelspaß der nicht sehr sicher man
vorher kennen uns sehr gut wir uns
selbst viel zeit zum warten der letzten
zeit und sebastian das wiso gutermann
dementsprechend lasst uns einfach alle
fan ist ich wollte drei kategorien
gegeneinander antreten werden einmal
wissensfragen zu meiner person damit
schnelligkeit war albert aus
selbstschutz fairport mit und zu guter
letzt ihr wisst dass ich liebe meinen
kaffee und meine kaffeemaschine eine
lache art bettet wehrpflicht bessere hsg
zu den ersten bissen zu beginn mit der
ersten frage wie viele aufrufe hat man
meist geklickten youtube video auf die
letzte ziffer genau so dass wir eure
antworten lauten 2,1 millionen und 27 34
millionen
die richtige antwort ist 2 million 908
nach 630 ich habe ein video oder um fast
eine million
wer keine bessere lösung zusammen mit
hut und die raserei und hat nicht vor
drei tagen nach nachgeschossen irgendwie
sowas in dem rechtsrheinischen oft wird
was nächste frage ich schwer denn ich
genau haben uns vor zwei wochen gesuchte
japan gebracht hat nach oben sonst hat
rund 81,7 berichtet über 280 kilo
terrain ab 27 die korrekte antwort sind
zwei haben sich die letzte frage ich
euch nur das verfahren wieder es
wirklich sehr lustig wieder habe ich von
meinem letzten abläuft kein video
geladen poker 34 tag der tat ab und
nicht mein tag ich habe 34 tage lang ein
video hochladen können wir darüber reden
die den brettern kann also die fressen
selbst bringt mit was ihr bekommt ist
weiter mit den speed fragen die er so
schnell es geht beantworten müsste frage
bin ich 21 jahren
zweite frage bin ich im fünften semester
ja du bist du bist also der reinigung
der wände währenddessen comparis das
kurze unterbrechung für ein paket was
ich bekommen habe leute ein komplett ihr
seht schon seit je voller erst mal kurze
gestrichen und für dieses paket ich habe
noch nie so ein schönes paket bekommen
und ich habe wirklich lange gewartet und
zu schauen was redest bis sich dieses
video aufnehmen
das metall hast du schon mal ein paket
mit metall bekommen hast schon bei dir
geklingelt werden und paket mit metall
ausgeprägt hast tatsächlich nicht so da
gar keine ahnung was drin ist wir haben
hier schon mal eine kopie vom spiel aber
ich glaube nicht irgendeinen irgendwie
mit das special aus dass hier ein
booklet mit dzeko sie später nämlich
verloren werden und eine festplatte mit
2 terabyte speichervolumen für die xbox
saic habe ich dafür verwenden sonst
steche ich die day by day hat man nichts
mehr galt schon mal die schau mal was
noch drin ist wo meine götter ein
fenster sie haben hier drin in der box
noch die post in dieser oft findet sich
ihr seht als erstes 32 noch mehr
features pro mente ich glaube das ist
richtig krass ich habe einfach einen
dell verstärkt
[Musik]
ok dann geht das laserschwert auch an
meine videobearbeitung street sind so
gut ich dazu nicht bewegen wird und mit
mega lights auf jeden fall ich danke
schön für dieses paket gerade die
vielleicht nicht wissen was geht voran
twitter überhaupt ist das neue star wars
gehen dazu kann auch mal ein video auf
meinen kanal ist jetzt einfach mal nicht
und die beschreibung da könnt ihr alles
da zu lesen
hallo ich habe schon gesagt haben
wiederholt damit europa geteilt die
letzte frage lautet dann bist du
vielleicht ein bisschen nachdenken nenne
eine person die mich sauer gemacht hat
die an texte stimmt irgendwie okay
das wird sie bestimmte sich artig die
seite heben namen aus der kumpel werden
können weil ist jedoch wahrscheinlich
sogar sauer gemacht hat jetzt vielleicht
day hat zwei punkte wirklich
entscheidende frage ist wer kann besser
lacht und deshalb will ich sagen sollte
ab geht's an die kaffeemaschine luft die
maschine nicht vorgeheizt auf die sache
ist das schon sagen dass ich in aller
regel hier sehr oft ich denke aber wir
halt keine latte art macht vielleicht
mit regel das ist kein muss nicht sehen
dazu sebastian bach geworden weil sie
können leichter ist es ein bisschen
schwierig jetzt für ihn da habe ich
schon ein bisschen übung so kann man
heute losgehen das ist okay dann wird
hier einmal wissen
aber mein gott gemacht und jetzt für den
wischer brauchen wir einmal kämpfte so
daneben dass nur noch wenig von einer
nicht näher genannten marke bin jetzt
aber
das ist immer die richtige menge milch
ist natürlich auch ein freies muss nicht
ist es zufall
es muss genau wie es interne schnabel
jetzt muss man da darf hinein lassen und
zwar so dass es so leicht unter die
oberfläche an geneigt street recht der
kirche ist richtig gut meinte forum
konto kann sich auch nicht gut dass wir
raus musik schon mal nicht abnehmen oder
der verwaltungsbau weiter überhaupt
keine ahnung davon jeden fall aber
eigentlich im ok machte es nochmal starb
hatte irgendwie das ist versichert sonst
würde das mal
man macht eine nacht genau mit dem schon
der am ende kommt ich habe das gemacht
warum
ist naja also wie kaffee genau was das
richtige für hard maxim's verweisen
ja aber du wolltest du sagen sie sehen
er sagte jetzt kommt es zu einer klima
auf der ich den weg überzeugen oder ihr
seht ihr trotzdem ist im selbstversuch
relativieren hat einmal den provisions
partys gibt um ein sehr interessanter
ansatz stellt mal direkt mit dem schauen
ist mir ganz wichtig store darauf habe
mega viel ausschütten muss dabei ist es
besser als wenn das wahr ist tut mir
leid
gewaltakte
[Musik]